ce n'est pas un jeu vidéo mais une
solution destinée au secteur de la santé
son nom mover ce produit présenté aux
crs 2010 9 de las vegas et conçu par la
start-up sky one portal basée à montigny
le bretonneux
je vais utiliser cet écran tactile pour
manipuler l'expérience changer la
vitesse de déplacement ajouter des
ballons des obstacles et le forcer à
effectuer certains mouvements pour
éviter les obstacles ou attraper les
ballons
l'objectif c'est de forcer le patient à
effectuer certains mouvements générés un
conflit sensorielle entre ce qu'il voit
et ce qu'il ressent physiquement
cette solution a été développée pour un
kinésithérapeute du pôle vertige
équilibre de montigny le bretonneux
déstabiliser le patient en faisant
disparaître la route accélérée ou
reculées des manipulations pour générer
un conflit sensorielle le but c'est de
les forcer à ne plus s'appuyer sur l'or
sur le visuel mais un peu plus sur leur
oreille interne ou la somme et stasi
c'est à dire le corps dans l'espace créé
en 2014 sky one portal est spécialisée
dans les solutions à usage immersive
lors du cs 2018 à las vegas la société a
créé un partenariat avec créative works
pour sa plateforme de jeu immersive
aujourd'hui créative works construit nos
produits pour le marché états unis dans
amérique australie nouvelle-zélande et
on a aussi un distributeur sur le japon
qu'à marcher aussi assez spécifique mais
c'est vrai que c'est aussi des
territoires où le notre solution de
divertissement fonctionnera votera bien
nouer des partenariats pour la
distribution des produits l'objectif de
la participation au cs avec à la clé une
activité dynamique
depuis sa création la start-up réalise
entre 50 et 100 % de croissance